the joggin experience did you see that
video of the octopus that had captured
an eagle that captured an eagle yes it
was in Vancouver Island I know the
octopus had captured an eagle and was
trying to eat the eagle and these
fishermen saw the struggle and released
the Eagle from the grasp of the octopus
suits to me is like that so here it is
right here holy crap that Eagles like
[ __ ] out bro help help
hello will help but to me it's weird
it's like why are you getting involved
in this right it's not like right like
people want to think that Eagles are an
endangered species they are absolutely
not endangered you go to Alaska they're
like pigeons up there they're they're
Giant Pacific octopus they're amazing
those oh yeah but that that's the thing
it's like I kind of like octopus more
than I like Eagles there's much smarter
they're way smarter yeah yeah they're
really interesting I mean I love Eagles
too right but you kind of got to lay a
play out look if I saw like a lion that
that eagle might not make it anyway look
at them right he's [ __ ] he's alone I'm
sorry water go happen what happened the
monkey people safe and the [ __ ] and
the Kraken yeah he was I don't even know
how the octopus got him but like what
octopus can do is nothing short of
spectacular you know we're talking about
my friend Remy Warren earlier and he had
a show on television before called apex
predator and it was basically they would
study apex predators and you know the
different strategies they used to be
successful as a hunter and when they did
the one on the octopus he you know he
was in here and like he was like dude
they're from another planet yeah he's
like that is the way they change their
texture right in their color and the way
they do it instantaneously to adapt to
their environment and how well they
blend in they're so interesting I think
they're the most alien creature that
exists on planet Earth yeah I agree
there's a there's a new documentary out
on I think it's PBS called making
contact that's just about octopus
intelligence is this guy he's a
fisheries biologist and he gets an
octopus and basically lives with it in
his living room
like he figures out that this thing
likes being petted like it knows how to
it's just it's the diverse array of
things that this thing can process
mentally it's like on par with like what
chimpanzees do you know I mean it's like
it's just like it can open jars it can
close them it can come out of the
aquarium go back into it it'll swim over
if it knows you it knows if it doesn't
like you like it's unbelievable yeah
really weird right yeah
dinah we got this video the octopus
dreaming I just looked it up and it
starts with the octopus this is my
living room this is it this is making
this video to purr viral yeah well they
apparently as the octopus is asleep and
dreaming it's changing the outside color
and texture of its skin in relation to
whatever the [ __ ] is going on in his
head right right so why not it's just so
weird how they can instantaneously
change their coloration and their
texture and then perfectly blend in with
coral right like when you see them like
stop on a coral reef and just become the
reef you like what ardently to it's like
and it's gone
the colors in this thing you know what
simcha there are actual there are people
that actually believe they are from out
of space
I've seen them enough to you that
there's biologists that believe that
they came in and asteroids and eggs you
got it yeah that's exactly think about
that I think like look I believe in life
outside of Earth but I don't I don't
necessarily think that octopus came from
that I think they're you know they have
other stuff like there are other
cephalopods that they're related to
genetically squid and cuttlefish and
things like that I don't necessarily
think they came from out of space but I
can see why there's science to support
that it's a possibility and then I can
also see why people think that seeing
them
well there's thoughts about that with a
lot of different life forms like spores
there's thoughts about that when it
comes to psilocybin mushrooms yep
there's like we're the real freaky
psychedelic heads think that psilocybin
mushrooms came from asteroids right and
and the proof and the pudding in that
one so to speak is the fact that you can
take mushroom spores into the vacuum of
space and bring them back to earth and
there they still they still fruit yeah
trying to grow weed right now to see
what happens out there you guys send a
little bit of weed into something on the
space station
test it for 30 days and see if it's
viable really some way that's when we
get into the weed business us and Elon
space weed SpaceX is wheatley LAN cent
weed in the space I don't think this is
the first time it's been done but the
story went around cuz it's it's
interesting because we knew was on here
I don't even think he inhaled no he's
growing weed in space
look what they're that octopus eggs look
like whoa and so they're developing
those intelligent chromatophores that
thing that basically the skin picks up
the color and changes to match mm-hmm
right there in the embryo yeah look at
their little eyeballs how weird and look
how many of them like an invasion you
imagine if your wife gave birth to that
many people no thanks you'd be like oh I
have a school school full of kids hey
first of all I'm getting [ __ ] snipped
look at that look how they drop off what
the matrix look like exactly do the
matrix is not that far off and it seems
like the further this further we go in
time and human evolutionary time the
more it seems like it's an act it's
accurate you know like we're getting
more and more plugged in every yeah it's
like a combination of the matrix and the
terminator yeah I'm very concerned about
the future of our species but but going
back to octopus octopus and cuttlefish
are closely related right and they both
can change the texture in their color
yeah cuttlefish have lacked
less textural changes they're more color
based okay what was the one they did
when they had him over a chessboard and
it was trying to meet you ever seen that
we're now who's just trying to mimic a
chessboard that's cool yeah is really
weird because it throws our system off
because it's any right angles and it's
it's hard fast yeah and the one zero
contrast so when you look at it like
this octopus like trying to like figure
out her right what to do yeah can you
see actual like lines in his color I
don't remember yeah I remember being
weird is it a cuttlefish yeah yeah see
if we could see it here it's very
strange pictures good
yeah look at that I mean that's pretty
good
like pretty [ __ ] good yeah look it's
got white squares man right the goddamn
things growing white squares started
with zebra stripes and then I think it
maybe it figured out the squares after a
couple that's pretty impressive I like
the picture in the bottom right there
where the guy looks like he's playing
chess against the cuttlefish I never
mind I thought there's a cuttlefish on
yeah just what a strange ability that
these animals have unbelievable figured
out I mean just how the [ __ ] did that
evolve right they're devising strategies
in order to be more effective predators
while they're in the ocean and hide from
other predators right and they've
figured out a way to change the color
and the texture of their skin like how
long did that take
exactly exactly millions of years
[Applause]